Anthony blinken the Secretary of State
for Joe Biden
just showed off some of his Riz when he
played a set of hoochie coochie man on a
left-handed Fender Stratocaster at the
global music diplomacy initiative
[Music]
and the world will know
what it's all about you know ahead
[Music]
everybody knows I'm here
I wanna hate it
I wanna hate it I'm waiting when I saw
this thumbnail load up I thought oh man
here comes the cringe gird your loins
hold on for dear comes the cringe and
then he started playing
and he's surprisingly good
it's not Jeff Beck you know it's not
he's not Jimi Hendrix he's not Muddy
Waters
but his rhythm playing was basically
fine it's kind of cool he's playing a
left-handed Strat his pitch and tone as
a singer surprisingly good it's hard for
white guys to sing uh songs that have
basically only ever been performed by
black guys or only ever been
persuasively performed by black guys and
he he did it pretty well I thought I was
actually pretty impressed this is today
is my day of saying nice things about
Democrats
I'm saying that Dianne Feinstein was not
the worst U.S senator by a long shot I'm
saying that Governor Bateman over there
in California might be a stone cold
psychopath who feeds stray cats to ATMs
but he's a political talent and I'm
gonna say Anthony blanken Secretary of
State
a pretty good little guitarist you know
he's got a decent pitch on him too and I
I really like that
I like it when politicians when
political leaders have hobbies when they
have other interests when they don't
then then I just assume they are pure
psychopathy that they are just absolute
100 grade A sociopathy whereas if like
Churchill if they paint you know if like
blinking if they play guitar and sing
Muddy Waters if they have other
interests it makes me think that they
are at least somewhat human
and they are not merely focused on the
acquisition of power for no other
purpose than wielding it right now go to
geniusell.com Knowles as you might know
we are all fans of our friends at gen
you sell don't just take my word for it
Ella from Rockford says I have both age
and acne spots and this stuff is
actually fading both of them this Serum
is worth every penny Ella is raving
about the famous Dark Spot Corrector
from genucel a must-have after months of
record heat and humidity sunspots brown
spots discoloration even red inflamed
patches all disappear in front of your
very eyes and here's the genu cell
amazing guarantee you will see results
on day one or your money back so take
advantage of geniusell's most popular
package which now includes the Dark Spot
Corrector plus the classic geniusell
bags and puffiness treatment and
immediate effects all for about seventy
seven zero percent off so you can try
the best skincare in the world for
yourself absolutely risk free it is very
simple you go to geniusell.com
years even decades younger tomorrow say
goodbye to dark and liver spots bags and
puffiness under the eyes and crow's feet
at genucel.com Knowles that is
geniusell.com
Knowles you guys remember threads
do you remember Facebook threads
that it's not as though I'm saying Hey
do you remember Myspace
hey do you remember live Journal hey do
you remember AOL Instant Messenger apps
from years and decades ago
Facebook rolled out threads which was
going to be its Twitter alternative
like two months ago or something
and now
I hadn't even remembered it until I was
on my Instagram account and I saw some
link to it I said oh right there's a
threat it's that thing that didn't that
completely flamed out CNBC is reporting
that upon the launch of Facebook threads
it looked like it posed a real chance of
of being a formidable competitor to
Twitter
and then it just collapsed
the forecast predicts a U.S user base of
23.7 million people for Threads in 2023.
that is
significantly less than half of the 56.1
million anticipated us users of X
formerly known as Twitter and Twitter
was always the smallest of the big
social media sites so compared to
Facebook Instagram and Tick Tock it's
relatively small because Facebook has
177.9 million users Instagram has 135.2
million and Tick Tock has
102.3 million
threads just completely
collapsed less than half of Twitter not
even registering in the conversation my
takeaway from this is it was in fact
smart of Elon to buy Twitter
at the time he bought it for 44 billion
dollars
people said this is a big waste of money
there's look maybe the company will
still go bankrupt to test financial
problems but if the point was for Elon
to have control over one of the big
Platforms in our Public Square to
actually get messages out there
it was smart to buy Twitter all the libs
said if Elon buys Twitter we're going to
get off Twitter we're going to stop
using it it's going to collapse we're
all going to go someplace else and they
don't
they don't and they never do they never
go to truth social they never go to
parlor they never go to gab they never
go to threads they never it's no knock
on any of those platforms
but
these platforms have a lot more staying
power and inertia than they have
previously been given credit for a lot
of people said well look you remember
Myspace and then Myspace went away so
some new company will do that's not how
it works anymore in those early days of
the internet and the New Media things
were a little more tempestuous than they
were they've really settled down though
and the institutions especially Google
especially Facebook and to a much lesser
degree Twitter
they control the Public Square this is
why it was so dangerous when the big
Tech platforms censored the hunter Biden
laptop story
including from private messages
because in a republic
such as we are supposed to be if you
control speech you control the whole
political order because of the way we
govern ourselves is supposedly by
persuading one another and deliberating
the Senate is called the greatest
deliberative body in the world we speak
to one another we make speeches we make
arguments and then we persuade enough
people to get some things done if you
control speech in the Public Square you
control effectively the whole political
order and that's what these
unaccountable billionaires in Silicon
Valley had been doing all for the left
Twitter comes in well Elon comes into
Twitter and just shifts it and makes it
more amenable to conservatives and it
worked and it had staying power
conservatives in recent years have been
eager to flee the old institutions they
say the old institutions are so hollowed
out so desiccated screw it let the libs
have them we're going to build our own
institutions it's good to start building
our own institutions obviously that's
what we're trying to do here at the
daily wire but that is not enough we
should not seed the institutions to the
left that's how we lost the universities
and the libs went in and hollowed out
those universities and made them zombies
of what they once were but they still
have some Prestige they still have some
influence if if we want to
get back to any state of normal in the
United States
we've got to fight over those we've got
to have hostile takeovers re-takeovers
of those institutions we need we need
Elon Musk and people like Elon Musk I
guess there aren't very many because
he's the richest man in the world to go
in and put their money where our mouths
are and take those institutions and kick
out the bad guys and turn them a little
bit more in the right direction and
start wielding them for our interests
which happen to be more in line with
Justice and virtue and a flourishing
Society don't give them up don't concede
them don't say well you're going to have
them it's all lost
tactical Retreats can be fine sometimes
you gotta tactically Retreat from
Harvard to Hillsdale to get your troops
back up but but that's only to mount
another attack on Harvard and go in and
take it sometimes you need to tactically
retreat from California to Texas or
California to Tennessee but not to say
we don't care what happens in California
anymore only so that you can get your
forces strong enough again to go back
there and fight those battles
in California and throughout the United
States so that we have a flourishing
Society
Sometimes the best defense is to go to
offense boy what a great clip that was
now but make sure that you ring the bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time